we're off to film with this german tv
channel
[Music]
gary let's
start off with um the political bits
that talk there's a lot of talk now and
actually informal government's already
of leveling up
yeah yeah what do you think about that
uh it's a great idea it'd be nice if
they did it um leveling up obviously
it's often not clear what it's meant
whether it's regional leveling up
um for me i'm an equality economist so
what i look at is poverty and if we look
at what's happened between individuals
during the covert crisis it's been the
biggest ever one year increase in wealth
for the rich and the super rich the
average british billionaire increased
their wealth by 630 million pounds in
the first year of covid which is amazing
and yet now we're seeing
ordinary families especially poor
families basically struggling to just
pay the bills so
in the last
two and a half years of this leveling up
government we've seen the poor driven
further into poverty and the rich seeing
the wealth exploding so for me
leveling up would be great but if you
look at what they're actually doing
it's not happening
how is that working why does it happen
that you pour money into
cause
poor people pockets by spending i don't
know 400 billion for what rishi soon
after and it all
trickles up i'm not down
yes that is excellent question um as you
make clear the government printed the
british government printed 450 billion
pounds during kovid that's ten thousand
pounds per adult
and most of that money was actually
given to people who were in quite
desperate need people who for example
had lost their jobs so how is it that it
ends up with the richest people at the
beginning of kobe i spent a lot of time
basically thinking about this because i
knew extra money was going in and i knew
it was going largely to furloughed
workers but i also knew that furloughed
workers were ending up poorer than they
were pre-covered so this money's being
poured in it's going directly to the
photos workers but they are not keeping
the money because they've lost their
incomes so you have to follow the money
through right where is the incomes of
the workers gone well they're not
getting paid their wages anymore so
we're going back to the companies are
the companies holding the money well
actually the companies are not because
they've lost their customers so if you
go back to the customers we actually see
it's customers who accumulated a huge
amount of money during covid and people
watching this might be thinking well i'm
a customer i haven't accumulated 10 000
pounds and the reason for that is
it's only customers who had very large
luxury and non-essential spending if
you're spending like most people is
large on essentials like rent mortgage
food bills you still had those
expenditures but if your expenditures
are largely luxuries and on essentials
you couldn't buy those things anymore
during kobe so what happened was the
rich and the super rich stopped spending
and the consequence was ordinary
families stopped being able to pay their
bills so the money went in to the poor
but straight away went back up to the
rich who accumulated it so you could
actually predict this right at the
beginning of codeword that there would
be an enormous increase in cash
accumulated by richer people during
covid and if you look at my videos and
articles at the beginning of coverage
you'll see that i did predict it and it
is exactly what's happened i'm we're
seeing the predictable consequences now
inflation house prices rising stock
prices are rising well that's what
happened in the last two years but even
before that um
britain seems such an in equal unequal
society
how did that happen over the years what
is the kind of
general
general thing apart from capitalism
if you look into the history of it you
know if you're interested in the history
you know it's actually worth reading
piketty the french economist book
capital at least the first couple of
chapters because he really looks into
the history of it you know the history
of inequality in this country it was
very very high in the pre-war period
then after the second world war it
became much much lower that was a period
of very high taxation you know famously
the beatles paid 95 percent taxation on
their income you know 19 for him and one
for me
um but in the 80s taxation of the riches
was decreased massively now if you don't
tax rich people i think it's important
to realize that rich people generate
huge amounts of income from their wealth
so if you have a wealth of 200 billion
pounds like 200 million pounds like our
chancellor you will get six million
pounds a year just for getting out of
bed you know so if the rich
don't pay taxes then naturally their
wealth will swell and they will take the
wealth of ordinary families i think this
is
this is the natural way of things if you
don't tax rich people rich people are
rich as a result they have huge incomes
and they can buy the assets
that has been support the centuries
obviously
um
do you feel there is a
rather high acceptance of inequality in
the uk
i think it really depends you ask i
think actually there's actually been a
kind of interesting change in tone of
this because i've been campaigning for
greater taxation of the richest for a
while now and i was talking about it 10
years ago when i was a trader and back
then people would say you can't tax the
rich because it's bad for the economy
and i think increasingly that kind of
manner of thinking has become less and
less popular i think increasingly people
can see that the last 10 15 years have
not worked for the economy or for
ordinary people so people are accepting
what's happening now is not working
economically but now when i say you need
to tax the rich people what comes back
is well you can't they'll leave so i
actually think what you've seen is
the rich have kind of lost the battle on
it's a moral good for us to be rich and
now they're saying well it doesn't
matter because you can't stop us
so
that's not the most positive response
but i think it shows more and more
ordinary people are accepting that the
levels of inequality now are way too
much and they're not working
um well actually it's a bit of a side
question but i ask it nevertheless we're
doing this also because there's a lot of
excitement in here but also in germany
about the jubilee of the queen
yeah and um we thought well it's nice to
do something about sweden you'd rather
want to do something about the state of
the uk economic state how is it going
for people 70 years after she came to
throw well you know
yeah i've never met the queen i'm sure
she's a lovely lovely lady and i hope
she's recovering from her covid very
well um
you know she resided over a period of
actually phenomenal economic strength in
this country if you look at back 50s 60s
70s you know my dad worked for the post
office for 25 years i think 35 years in
fact he never earned a lot of money but
he was able to buy a house support three
kids you know and now he's retired
you know not too long ago that was
possible in this country
but now you have people working that
kind of job who are literally homeless
because they can't afford to pay the
rent
so
during the period the queen has been the
queen we've seen some really amazing
economic times you know where ordinary
people have been able to
live good lives working ordinary jobs
but unfortunately we're losing that now
and increasingly ordinary people earning
ordinary jobs can't afford to own
property or even get financial security
you know i get message all the time from
young people who are smart ambitious
doing everything right going to the
right uni studying hard and they can't
afford to buy a house they can't afford
to become financially secure so um
you know i wouldn't like to point their
finger at the queen directly but yeah
we've lost a lot
my question would be is there not kind
of baked in inequality in this country
because you have a monarch i mean people
accept that people are born into
something special and rich and
it's okay
listen every country has inequality
but that level of inequality changes you
know what i campaigned for inequality
and sometimes people turn around to me
and say you're never going to get
perfect equality and i say look
that may or may not be true but you can
stop inequality from killing your
economy you know 50 years ago inequality
was much less than it is now and
inequality in the last 20 years has
increased significantly so
i don't like this fatalistic attitude
that you will always have inequality
because you know
it is true you always have inequality
but if you allow it to destroy your
economy your economy will still be
destroyed you know what i mean we still
need to manage this and it's growing and
growing you know i've been analyzing the
economy for 10 15 years now and i've
been betting on disaster because of
inequality and i keep being right and i
don't want to be right you know
you know your car will never be perfect
but you know if part of it is broken you
still need to fix it and the economy is
the same you know we will never have a
perfect economy but we can have a much
better one than we have now
what was your motivation to be become a
trader
i was poor and i wanted to be rich you
know i come from a very poor family you
know and
i help my brother get a house i help my
sister get a house you know i take care
of my parents
you know i was poor i know it's like to
be poor when you're poor ain't no one
going to come out and make you not poor
unless you do it yourself
that's what i wanted to do and that's
what i did
and once you have the feeling okay now i
can do this that was it
yeah i mean i was always like
smart
good at maths at school you know i just
thought why not me you know i went to a
good universe you know i was one of the
top students and
yeah i thought i could do it when i went
into the city and i realized the truth
is it's
there are some smart people there but
it's not full of geniuses yeah you know
i'm as good as anyone why can't i be the
top trade in the city and i was
you could have gone on made loads of
money and spread it around
yeah but you know i literally made money
by betting on economic disaster you know
and that's that's not a ideological
thing my job was to analyze the economy
i analyzed the economy my conclusion was
we have a serious structural problem of
inequality it's not being dealt with
it's not going to be dealt with we will
have a disaster i bet on that and then
by the end of that year i was the top
trade in the world for one of the
world's biggest banks you know
you don't need to be mahatma gandhi to
say something should be done here you
know what i mean if your job is to
analyze fire security and the result is
the whole city is going to burn down
what are you going to do you're not just
going to bet on it you're going to try
and tell people you know um
look i'm a very good economist i've been
paid very very well because i understand
what's happening i think we have a
problem which is very serious and
getting worse but it's fixable and i
want us to fix it because i don't want
the world to be terrible it's not
complicated
have you been approached by the labour
party
um i don't want to name individual names
but i have spoken some labor mps um
there's a reshuffle recently they
haven't spoken to me since um but i'm
here you know and i'm open to the
conservatives as well i call out richard
sonic often because he's very wealthy
and he's a chancellor so he's very
powerful
i'd be delighted to speak to him about
ways they could improve the economy um
yeah i'm open to it you can give them my
number if you know him
sun's gone
i strongly suspect you wouldn't yes
um
what else i want to say energy prices
let's talk about energy prices sarah
went to burnley and filmed with some
really
poor people in the proper sense of the
world
yeah what what do these energy prices
tell us i mean obviously everybody was
like oh the energy prices are going up
we can't do anything against it and
unfortunately now you have to pay them
yeah
okay the energy price situation is very
very serious okay it's a really
significant extra cost on families who
cannot afford to pay it you know we're
talking about people will be driven into
poverty not able to hit their homes not
able to feed their families not able to
pay their rent their mortgages people
become homeless this is really really
really serious um
the message i would like to put out
there is that in the last two years
we have seen an unprecedented increase
in millionaire and billionaire wealth
and that's a result of the way we dealt
with the coping crisis so
people are given this message that this
is almost like an act of god or at least
it's because of the war prices have gone
up there's nothing we can do but at the
same time we've seen the average
billionaire increase to us by 630
million pounds in this country a single
year 22 increase in billionaire and
millionaire wealth the biggest ever
single year increase and yet we're
sitting here with a cost of living
crisis which means ordinary people can't
pay the bills and we're saying there's
nothing we can do there's no money it's
it's
it's mind-blowing to me you know why are
people not pointing out the fact that
the rich and the super rich have made an
unprecedented and unprecedented amount
of money in the last two years if you
tax them
then there's no crisis but we're not
talking about it and it's
it's driving me mad and you know that's
why i'm talking about it